Доброго дня! Мене звати
Дар’я і це фізика 9-го класу.
Сьогодні ми розберемо
«Рух тіла під дією кількох сил»,
а саме - будемо розглядати
рух у вертикальному напрямку.
Для задач на дію кількох сил на
тіло нам дуже важливий алгоритм.
Отже, виведемо його на екран.
Перше, що нам необхідно
робити в таких задачах -
це зображати всі сили, що діють на тіло.
Давайте візьмемо найпростіший приклад.
Візьмемо книжку, яка лежить на столі.
Отже, в нас є стіл, є книга.
Перше, зображаємо сили,
що діють на книгу в цей момент.
Перше, що ми точно знаємо, це те, що
на книгу діє сила тяжіння, адже
вона знаходиться на планеті Земля.
Отже, малюємо вектор сили тяжіння.
Сила тяжіння - це mg (маса на
прискорення вільного падіння).
Якби це була єдина
сила, що діє наразі на тіло,
то книга б в нас падала під
дією цієї сили з прискоренням.
Втім, стіл, на якому лежить
книга, не дає книзі впасти.
А отже, існує певна опора і сила
збоку цієї опори, це є сила реакції опори.
Сила реакції опори спрямована в
протилежний бік і позначається як N.
Так само, це векторна величина, бо вона
має напрямок, тому я намалювала тут риску.
Отже, перший етап виконано.
Ми зобразили всі сили, що діють на тіло.
Лише один дуже важливий момент: насправді,
сила реакції опори та сила тяжіння
не мають спільну точку прикладання.
Якщо малювати більш точно,
то якщо сила тяжіння
діє на центр тяжіння тіла,
тобто точка прикладання в нас
дійсно знаходиться по центру,
то сила реакції опори, її точка
прикладання, відповідно, іде від опори.
Тобто, насправді, точка
прикладання цієї сили знаходиться тут.
Але, при розв’язуванні задач
на рух тіла під дією кількох сил,
ми будемо нехтувати розмірами тіла
або, інакше кажучи, приймати
його за матеріальну точку
і відкладати всі сили
від однієї спільної точки.
Отже, це було щодо зображення сил.
Наступний пункт - це запис другого
закону Ньютона у загальному вигляді.
Нагадаю, другий закон Ньютона каже нам, що
якщо на тіло діють сили, які
нескомпенсовані між собою,
то тіло буде рухатись із прискоренням.
Записати другий закон Ньютона у загальному
вигляді або у векторному вигляді
означає позначити у векторному вигляді всі
сили, що діють на наше тіло, їхню суму,
тобто в нашому випадку - це
сила реакції опори плюс сила тяжіння
і, за другим законом Ньютона,
це дорівнює: маса
помножити на прискорення.
Втім, книжка стоїть, відповідно
прискорення дорівнює нулю.
А якщо прискорення дорівнює
нулю, то сума ця дорівнює нулю.
Тобто маса помножити на нуль, буде нуль.
Отже, замість ma, в нашому
випадку, коли тіло покоїться
(не рухається з прискоренням під
дією цих сил), ми напишемо нуль.
Наступне, що ми маємо зробити - це
обрати системи координат ОХ та ОY.
В нашому випадку - обираємо
лише систему координат ОY,
адже по Х в нас тіло не рухається.
Що означає обрати систему координат?
По факту, в нашому випадку, це
означає задати куди дивиться наша вісь ОY.
Нехай в неї буде наступний
напрямок: ось так, вгору.
Для чого нам це важливо?
Нам важливо задати напрямок
осі для наступного кроку,
коли ми будемо проектувати сили,
що діють на наше тіло на цю вісь.
Що означає спроектувати?
Це означає
записати це рівняння
у модульному вигляді.
Інакше кажучи, коли ми
проектуємо, нам важливо
чи ця сила дивиться в той самий
бік, як і вісь, чи в протилежний?
І залежно від цього, ми будемо
писати або плюс, або мінус
перед нашою силою, перед нашою величиною.
Тобто коли ми проектуємо
нашу силу реакції опори на цю вісь,
ми бачимо, що вона дивиться
в той самий бік, як і вісь.
Значить ми її запишемо додатною,
її значення додатне, з плюсом.
Сила тяжіння, якщо ми її проектуємо,
то бачимо, що вона дивиться у
протилежний бік від напрямку осі.
Значить, сила тяжіння в
нас піде зі знаком мінус.
Як ви бачите, я вже записую
без ось цих векторних “шапочок”,
тому що мова вже йде про значення.
Дорівнює, і так само нуль лишається.
Звідси, якщо ми перекинемо нашу
силу тяжіння праворуч від дорівнює,
ми отримаємо, що сила
реакції опори дорівнює mg.
Через це багато хто вважає,
що сила реакції опори
протидіє силі тяжіння,
адже вони рівні за значенням
та протилежні за напрямком.
Втім, насправді, тут є хибна думка.
Адже якщо ми подивимось на цей
малюнок, що ми зобразили на початку,
то побачимо, що точка прикладання
цих сил знаходиться в різних місцях.
Відповідно вони не можуть
врівноважувати одна одну.
Насправді, через те, що
точки прикладання різні,
то під дією цих сил тіло,
ніби трошки стискається.
Воно деформується.
Можна намалювати це ось так.
Воно трошки прогинається.
І через те, що з’являється
ось цей прогин, ця деформація,
виникає сила пружності, яка
намагається нібито розпрямити тіло.
І ось ця сила, що при цьому
виникає, називається вага.
Отже, саме вага, яка
пов’язана із силою пружності,
що виникає при деформації
від дії цих двох сил.
Саме вага
є силою, що завжди протидіє
силі реакції опори та дорівнює їй.
Таким чином,
сила реакції опори завжди дорівнює вазі.
Це в нас була демонстрація сил, що діють
на книжку, яка знаходиться в стані спокою.
Тепер уявімо, що мова йде не про книжку,
а мова йде про ліфт, який
рухається прискорено вгору.
Отже, в нас є ліфт.
Нехай в ньому знаходиться якесь
тіло (чи то людина, чи та сама книга).
Повторюємо наш алгоритм.
Які сили діють в цей момент на наше тіло?
Спершу, звичайно, що сила тяжіння.
Далі, сила реакції опори.
Ми відчуваємо, як
підлога ліфта тисне на нас.
Отже, сила реакції опори.
І при цьому наш ліфт
рухається вгору із прискоренням.
Перший крок виконано, ми зобразили сили.
Наступне - записуємо другий закон Ньютона.
Записуємо у векторному вигляді суму.
Увага на дошку!
Прискорення наявне, значить тут в нас вже,
на відміну від попереднього
випадку із книгою, буде ma.
Наявне прискорення.
Третій крок - обираємо систему координат.
Так як ліфт рухається вгору, нехай вісь ОY
зростає у цьому напрямку .
Четвертий крок - проектуємо.
Тобто дивимось, N у нас дивиться
в той самий бік, як і вісь ОY,
значить N піде із додатнім знаком.
mg (сила тяжіння) дивиться в
протилежний бік від напрямку осі,
відповідно - ставимо мінус mg.
І дорівнює ma за другим законом Ньютона.
Прискорення в нас так само
дивиться в той самий бік, як і вісь.
Тому прискорення буде із додатнім знаком.
З цього випливає, що
сила реакції опори дорівнює
mg + ma.
Можемо винести масу за дужки
і тоді в дужках залишиться g + a.
Ми з вами вже казали, що
сила реакції опори та вага,
тобто сила, з якою ми тиснемо на
підпору або підвіс, якщо ми висимо,
дорівнюють одна одній.
Значить, в цьому випадку, коли
ліфт рухається прискорено вгору -
наша вага так само зростає.
Так, як N=P, то наша
вага так само зростає.
І це, насправді, дуже важливий момент,
його потрібно враховувати,
якщо мова йде про запуски ракет.
Тому що, коли в нас, наприклад,
космонавтів запускають в космос,
то ракета рухається прискорено вгору,
і через те, що виникає це
прискорення - вага зростає.
Ось цей момент, коли вага зростає через
рух вертикально вгору із прискоренням,
він називається перевантаження.
Інколи ці сили стають настільки
великими, тобто вага настільки зростає,
що це може дуже негативно
відбитися на здоров’ї космонавтів.
Тому за цим дуже ретельно слідкують.
І саме тому космонавти
проходять дуже багато перевірок,
це перевантаження, це
збільшення власної ваги.
Повертаючись до
порівняння ваги і сили тяжіння.
Ми казали, що вага дорівнює сили
реакції опори і дорівнює силі тяжіння mg,
лише коли тіло знаходиться в стані спокою.
Не треба плутати вагу і силу тяжіння.
Тому що вони мають ряд відмінностей.
Перше те, що ми з вами вже визначили.
Сила тяжіння - це гравітаційна сила.
В неї зовсім інша природа.
Вага тіла - це сила пружності.
Сила тяжіння має точку
прикладання в центрі тяжіння тіла.
Вага тіла має точку прикладання до опори.
Так само, вага тіла не
завжди дорівнює силі тяжіння -
те, що ми з вами тільки що побачили.
Наприклад, якщо тіло рухається
вертикально вгору, то вага тіла зростає.
Сила тяжіння лишається такою самою.
Відповідно, ми розуміємо, що вага
тіла може так само і зменшуватись.
Це, як ви вже можете здогадатись,
буде відбуватися в тому випадку,
коли ліфт буде рухатися
із прискоренням вниз.
Це рівняння в нас лишиться без змін,
коли ми будемо проектувати.
Єдине, що зміниться - це
прискорення буде дивитися в
протилежний від напрямку осі бік,
а значить вираз ma
запишемо зі знаком мінус.
Звідси
сила реакції опори буде дорівнювати:
перекидаймо mg на той бік.
Це сила реакції опори.
Так як ми сказали, що сила
реакції опори дорівнює вазі,
то наша вага при цьому буде
зменшуватися на це прискорення а.
Тобто в цьому випадку вага
буде дорівнювати:
Отже, бачимо, що
залежно від того, чи тіло рухається
вертикально вгору з прискоренням,
чи вертикально вниз з прискоренням - наша
вага буде збільшуватися або зменшуватися.
Сила тяжіння лишиться такою самою.
Подивіться, що цікаво
ось в цьому рівнянні,
коли в нас тіло рухається
вертикально вниз.
Напевно, багато хто з вас чув
про таке явище, як невагомість.
Подивіться на це рівняння.
Коли в нас буде невагомість?
Тобто коли вага буде дорівнювати нулю?
В тому випадку, коли тіло
буде рухатись із прискоренням g,
що дорівнює прискоренню вільного падіння.
Інакше кажучи, якщо ми
обірвемо трос нашого ліфта,
і він буде рухатись у вільному
падінні, виключно під дією сили тяжіння.
Тобто, із прискоренням вільного падіння.
Інакше кажучи, якщо я зараз,
наприклад, візьму маркер і підкину його,
то в цей момент коли він летить,
він перебуває в невагомості,
адже він падає вниз із прискоренням g.
I g мінус g буде дорівнювати нулю.
Або, якщо так буде зрозуміліше, то
немає опори - немає ваги,
адже вага - це сила із якою тіло діє на
опору, внаслідок його притягання до землі.
Отже, невагомість у
нас буде в тому випадку,
коли тіло рухається
виключно під дією сили тяжіння
Отже, перевантаженням
називається збільшення ваги тіла,
викликане його прискореним
рухом вертикально вгору.
Якщо тіло рухається з
прискоренням вертикально вниз,
то його вага зменшується, відповідно
через віднімання від прискорення
вільного падіння цього прискорення,
з яким тіло рухається
вертикально вниз у формулі.
І з цього випливає, що, якщо
тіло рухається із прискоренням вільного
падіння вертикально вниз, тобто падає,
то воно перебуває у цей
момент у стані невагомості.
Адже тоді, дія в дужках
вже (-а = 0), адже а = g.
І у зв’язку з цим існує
хибне твердження, що
наприклад, на міжнародній
космічній станції
(це така станція, яка обертається
на орбіті навколо Землі),
що там існує невагомість через те, що
там не відчувається дія земного тяжіння.
Це абсолютно хибне твердження.
Тому що міжнародна космічна станція
розміщена всього лише
на висоті 400 км від Землі.
Якщо порівнювати цю відстань із радіусом
Землі, що складає близько 6 тисяч 400 км,
то ця відстань взагалі незначна для того,
щоб сила тяжіння якось суттєво впала.
Тому там вона наявна.
Причина, чому ж космонавти перебувають
там в невагомості, полягає в наступному.
Уявіть собі, що в нас є
коробка з апельсинами.
Коли коробка знаходиться в стані спокою,
то апельсини тиснуть
на коробку своєю вагою.
Якщо ж тепер ми візьмемо цю коробку,
підкинемо її, та вона буде падати, тобто
буде знаходитися в стані вільного падіння,
тоді і апельсини, і коробка будуть падати
з однаковим прискоренням вільного падіння.
Адже ми знаємо, що коли на
тіла діє виключно сила тяжіння,
то вони будуть рухатися незалежно від
маси із прискоренням вільного падіння g.
Таким чином виходить, що
коробка ніби тікає з-під апельсинів
із таким самим прискоренням,
з яким падають апельсини.
Отже, вони просто не
можуть торкнутися тієї коробки,
а якщо в нас немає опори, то немає і ваги.
Це і є невагомість, що
пояснюється вільним падінням.
Так ось, теж саме
відбувається і на орбіті,
тільки замість коробки -
міжнародна космічна станція,
а замість апельсинів - космонавти.
Але принцип той самий.
Увага на слайд!
Тому людина, яка знаходиться на
орбіті, на міжнародній космічній станції -
просто не може тиснути на підлогу.
Вона від неї тікає і з таким
самим прискоренням,
з яким рухається там людина,
так само під дією сили тяжіння.
Тепер прийшов час розв’язати якусь задачу.
Нехай задача звучить наступним чином.
Увага на екран!
Отже, запишемо коротку умову.
В нас є прискорення, що
дорівнює 40 м/с в квадраті,
в нас є маса космонавта - 70 кг,
і треба знайти з якою силою
космонавт тисне на крісло.
Про яку силу йде мова?
Сила, з якою ми тиснемо на горизонтальну
опору, в нашому випадку крісло, це є вага.
Отже, треба знайти, яка
буде вага у цьому випадку.
Малюємо наше тіло - нашого космонавта.
На нього з одного боку діє сила тяжіння,
з іншого боку - сила реакції опори.
При цьому він стартує на ракеті,
яка рухається вертикально
вгору з прискоренням а.
Записуємо другий закон Ньютона.
Обираємо вісь.
Задаємо її напрямок таким чином.
Проектуємо.
N дивиться в той самий
бік, а значить додатне.
mg - в протилежний, а значить від’ємне;
ma - в той самий, значить додатне.
А так, як вага дорівнює
силі реакції опори.
Увага на дошку!
В нас все є, прискорення вільного
падіння, зазвичай, в таких задачах
береться за 1О м/с в
квадраті, округлене значення.
Отримаємо, що вага дорівнює.
Увага на дошку!
Рахуємо.
3500 Ньютонів, адже мова йде про силу.
Або, це так само можна записати,
як 3,5 кН,
адже "кіло" - це є тисяча, це як
множення на тисячу, на десять у третьому.
Таким чином, ми визначили у скільки
разів зростає вага нашого космонавта,
внаслідок вертикального
прискореного руху ракети вгору.
Тож сьогодні ми дослідили рух тіла під
дією кількох сил у вертикальній площині.
З’ясували різницю між вагою,
силою реакції опори та силою тяжіння,
зокрема прийшли до
висновку, що вага і сила тяжіння
не дорівнюють одна одній у всіх випадках,
та це взагалі сили зовсім різної природи.
Також ми дізналися про такі явища,
як невагомість та перевантаження
і з’ясували чому на
міжнародній космічній станції,
на орбіті, космонавти
відчувають невагомість.
На сьогодні все.
Дякую за увагу.
До нових зустрічей!